um
okay there was one where a friend who
had cheated on his partner quite a lot
um
basically which friend name him
he's watching i said in the group chat
um yeah where he went to a house party
uh after him and his girl got back
together
and
he like he he loved that girl like he
told us all the time he's like yeah this
thing i'm gonna marry
and then
he gets his house party now he i was
with him he was on his best behavior
and but there was a girl with us and
then they were just like chilling
whatever having having a laugh
and then by the end of the night because
he was waved and then he was like oh
yeah yeah we're gonna get the same cab
home because like she's going in my
direction i'm gonna hop out
and then i'm looking in like big mess up
lines we just go in the cab man
i don't care
yeah
turns out in the morning he calls us
guys
i didn't be here i didn't
he still did other stuff but he was so
happy with himself they didn't beat it
because like i've changed i've changed i
didn't wait but he did others
oh my god he didn't register that he
still cheated on his girlfriend yeah
because that's so sad
he saw when he saw him turning down
having sex with that girl i was like
okay clearly i can't do this anymore i
need to go back to any week he was sorry
he was so excited we like when he called
us in the group chat so excited are they
still together oh god no
did she find out
i'm actually not sure how to ask him
tomorrow okay
how many girls did he do that with like
too many
like more more than you could count um
the ones i saw a lot was he really good
looking
he was all right you know
okay
you know
men they are not that good looking they
are actually the ones who cheat more
that's what i heard there's not even the
good lookings like the hard ones how'd
you know that because i know some
friends they had that experience here
and in portugal like that ugly boyfriend
was cheating on yeah which is like funny
it's really funny
exactly
um okay do you think
that
um oh i asked this earlier but i don't
know if you guys responded dude who do
you think cheats more men are women just
go around everyone women women men
men
always thought women cheat more but
don't ever get caught they don't get
caught
at all and it was when i was at uni and
i was living i was the only guy in my in
my
flat and i saw some wildlife literally
trust me
or just delinquency
i think women cheat in different ways so
i think women will accept like a guy's
time attention and resources while in a
relationship yeah so she'll have like
guy friends that like clearly want to
bang her
like and just like put them in the
friend zone
and i think that's like a form of like
like what's the joke what's funny you're
you're right
you're right is that what you do yeah no
like because i think i feel like girls
we always know
if like a guy wants 100
100
okay so i think that's that's a
different form of cheating or like girls
will accept
like flirt with guys a little bit more
because they can to be honest or like
i've seen girls like at bars like like
twerking on another dude i'm like okay
but that's shh
what are you doing
i think that's what's the stop what's
the step oh this
yes
okay
it's it's equal about um men do but two
percent more so it's like twenty-five
percent
one survey yeah two percent more but i i
have an inkling that women do it more
they just don't get caught to be honest
because oh my god i have a story i've
told this story before in the podcast
but i'm gonna tell it again this girl
have you ever noticed that i'm
curious if the women like girls will
date a new guy
but still be in love with the ex
have you yeah yeah have you noticed that
i've never been in a relationship but
you've never been in a relationship
okay but like um maybe
like your friends like they'll date a
new guy but still be in love with the
guy they had a situation with or even
though they're with some some someone
new i would never know yeah so one
situation i could think of in college
was this girl and you would never know
she wasn't a big drinker she wasn't a
big party she didn't put her ass on the
internet you would never know she kind
of she looks like you're like girl next
door like very very nice girl
and freshman year of college she was
with this one guy okay
and they would they would like hook up
for like a month okay then he was just a
player he was like
five
seven
so i didn't know why she was like
tripping and
it'd be one thing if he had like any
ambition or drive or anything more to
offer i didn't get it like i just did
not get it but anyways she was obsessed
with this man he dumps her right a
couple years later she's dating
this new guy he's really nice like
honestly he bought her a house she moves
her into ah
bought our house they're living together
in this house okay
and there was a party senior year of
college
and um i i'm at this like dardy i'm like
you know i'm shimmying it's like a good
day like it's like
and i i i'm like it's weird i haven't
seen her in a minute the guy the
boyfriend's not there okay
and
i see her walk out of the bathroom with
the guy from freshman year at that party
and then yeah
and like cause i hadn't seen her in like
a half hour you know what i'm saying and
so then later that boyfriend comes to
the party
ah no way no and i just knowing her i
don't think she would have put that she
cheated on that survey
if she was surveyed on it yeah because
that's what i mean that survey's not
gonna be that accurate because no i feel
like oh did you cheat people are gonna
lie and say they didn't when they have
yeah no it can't be accurate yeah it
can't be because how would you and i
haven't taken that subway so who did
they get that survey from that
i don't know actually not off the top of
my head i can tell you that they didn't
survey every single person so no i think
they just they do it like it's a general
representation of the population
something like that
but yeah that's my crazy cheating story
i feel like
i think guys don't go out of their way
to search
if their girls cheat most guys don't go
out the way to search if their girls
cheating if they think that if they
think that girls cheating
more time they're just going to go cheat
themselves
they're not good words of god if a girl
thinks that man is cheating she's gonna
go after her
into sherlock holmes immediately and
she's gonna find out everything dates
phone numbers surnames second guys
that's so crazy i would never do that
i would never
so it's just like
yeah guys guys
have a different reaction
to that i would say do you okay do you
think that in a relationship you should
have each other's passcodes and
passwords no no i haven't no if you've
got i've done it
yeah i've i've done it um
at a certain point i was like you know
what i have nothing to hide like
i don't care like
but i've done that in the sense of if my
phone if if i need you set in love on my
phone do it it's
i don't think people should be going
through their partner's phone yes
exactly i feel like it could be open
yeah but then if they're using your
if they're looking for your phone just
because you two are together just
looking through photos but then if
they're looking for the fact that
they're searching to see oh did he
message this girl they're looking to see
are you cheating that's why they're
trying they're trying to find something
that's maybe not even there that's like
but at the same time you don't think
sometimes the girls have like intuition
and so so it's like what else are you
supposed to do yeah
like if you
because he's not going to have wrong if
they're wrong if they think you're
cheating or whatever
and
they're searching for it you might not
even be
cheating or whatever and it's gonna make
it's gonna negatively impact the
relationship i just think we need to get
rid of it all together i had a girl go
through my phone after seven days
seven days that's super even through my
phone
oh it's just a story in it um like
so
long story short i must have logged into
like i don't know just eat or delivery
or something okay
and
i think it saved my password so when she
was going to log into instagram
for some she saw it saved my stuff
and then she just clicked it went
through my whole dm so after seven days
seven days that's crazy crazy i think if
you're married you should have each
other's passions
i do think if you're mad i don't think
in a relationship so much but if you're
married like you shouldn't have anything
to hide if you're married that's what i
mean if you've got nothing to hide then
why not
but like i think at the other end you
don't want to be like obsessive to where
you're always like you need your
although everything's shared and you're
together you need your personal space
yeah yeah yeah you do
you need to be separate otherwise you
can be too clingy
yeah yeah and i think like every time
i've been in a situation where i want to
like look through a guy's phone like
it's because like i shouldn't be with
the guy 100 yeah it's like i shouldn't
be with him to begin with yes
if you're together you're like okay not
long together if you're married you're
basically
at that point you become one person
you you have yourself
but really and truly you are one person
at that point so
just the thought of having something the
other person can't access
at all is kind because think of it like
a bank account
if you're married and you've been
married for like 10 years and the other
person has no access to a certain bank
account is that is that is that not
weird
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's weird right
your partner can't yeah
there shouldn't be any secrets basically